in today's money money money money watch
we've got some last minute tax tips in
case you haven't filed yet a lot of you
haven't the deadline to submit your 2022
taxes is coming up or you got to ask for
an extension just five days away that
it's Tuesday April 18th that is the drop
dead day now as of March 31st the IRS
says that nearly 63 million folks have
filed and they've gotten refunds the
average refund about two thousand nine
hundred dollars that is some serious
money CBS News business analyst Joe
Schlessinger joins us now with more on
how you can get some of that serious uh
okay Jill so for people who haven't
filed their taxes yet don't panic right
yeah what do they do don't get in your
head about this we really Drive
ourselves crazy but if you're like most
of Americans so it's crazy because we're
scourging yeah well think about this
about 90 percent of us are filing with a
standard deduction it should literally
take you an hour to do this you've got
to use electronic filing more than
anything else this will really help
guide you and when you electronically
file you don't have the same propensity
to make an error the IRS says when you
have a paper return the error rate goes
way up because you actually have to
check what did I write down on my social
security number what did I match this up
the correct way that the big mistakes
are preventable and often they are silly
but you know it's a pain in the neck to
amend it so it is better to do it the
first the first time out the right way
so I use an Electrify electronically and
what's nice is if you use the same
software the information is populated
from years past so it makes it that much
easier but it's not free it costs a
little money so for people who are
looking for free resources and they want
to follow so there is something called
IRS free file this is a great resource
for people who make not a ton of money
you know like you can get the software
for free but some of them will put you
in touch with software providers walk
you right through it and what's
interesting about this if you could make
up to 73 000 and get free file that's
amazing there's another resource I don't
think a lot of people know about it's
the volunteer tax assistance program or
Vita this is great it is aimed at low to
medium earners and it can help people
you get actually a person who will walk
you through and there's tax counseling
for the elderly these are folks who are
great they'll hold your hands if you're
over the age of 60 they'll hold your
hands through a lot of the issues that
people have a hard time with like well
how do I count Social Security is it
income is it not these are resources
that are available and those are free
all free so what you're saying is all
well and good and people say but I still
need to file an extension I'm busy easy
easy to do form 4868 the thing about an
extension is you will get an extra six
months great no problem after six months
you'll get an extra sales penalty uh
without a penalty however you have to
pay what you think you owe at bedtime
uh-huh and so that means that right now
if you made a lot more money last year
than you did the prior year you might
have to send the IRS some money and the
thing that people forget about is that
maybe you sold a house maybe you
actually sold a stock last year so this
can contribute to extra tax liability
pay what you think you owe but file an
extension is easy it's really important
extension is an extension to file but
not to pay I think probably the number
one reason why people do not files
because they think they owe and they
don't have it in their bank account
right now they're not going to be able
to pay it so what do you do then you
know what you are not the first person
to be in that situation so please don't
worry the IRS has a lot of payment
programs and they do talk to you they're
not mean people these are wonderful
civil servants they will put you on an
installment plan now you can get a
short-term plan this will give you an
extra four months to pay you can also be
on a long-term installment plan where
you can pay a certain amount every month
and they'll work with you there's one
last part that I think people fall and a
trap were you screwing up your face this
doesn't look like I know will people use
their credit cards to pay their tax
bills and I don't love that and I'd
rather you be on a short-term
installment plan or a longer term plan
credit card companies charge fees for
this and we'd rather you not go into
credit card debt and there are penalties
and interest for from the IRS but
they're lower than what a credit card
would charge absolutely Joe what's going
on with these forms form 4868 1099 where
are they coming up with these numbers uh
it's just part of the IRS
it's awfully fun well this is one of the
things that I think gets in people's
heads it becomes complicated just know
it gang you can do this you're an adult
this is actually in the programs that
you are using so go get them get your
Moolah 2 900 bucks
you're an adult Tony you're an
additional you can do it Joe sluster
thank you very much